les membres des forces armées n'était
même pas au courant jusqu'à ce que
radio-canada le leur apprennent depuis
un mois leur radiographie ultrasons et
résonance magnétique ne sont plus
accessibles
ce vétéran n'en revient pas c'est
extrêmement important c'est très
inquiétant
on parle ici de dizaines voire de
centaines de milliers d' images
médicales pouvant remonter au milieu des
années 2000 les conséquences pourraient
être graves par exemple pour des soldats
qui ont été blessés en afghanistan selon
monsieur chartrand avec une hauteur des
ventes ils combattent 9 7 avec des
données antérieures ou mais cela s'est
produit qui vont déterminer
l'accessibilité aux soins que l'individu
à voir donc ces données là c'est un
problème informatique qui a tout
déclenché début avril
le système d'archivage et de
transmission d'image de l'armée le pacs
a été atteint c'est là où sont stockées
toutes les images radiologiques les
forces armées en quête toujours mais
confirme que le problème ne résulte pas
d'un cyber incident ou d'un accès
inappropriés ou donner mais plutôt d'une
erreur technologique
cependant le silence de l'armée depuis
un mois dérange aujourd'hui à 20,21
gérer la sécurité par l'obscurité je le
dénonce toujours ça n'a pas sa place cet
ancien officier de sécurité informatique
au ministère de la défense ne s'explique
pas que le pacs ne soit pas encore remis
en fonction ce qui laisse présager
plusieurs situations c'est à dire c'est
un problème très grave qui nécessite un
repentir au complet du système qui est
pas souhaitable mais en même temps
est-ce que c'est aussi un manque de
ressources humaines et ou techniques qui
empêchent la récupération rapide de ce
système non
heureusement les dossiers médicaux des
soldats sont intactes y compris les
rapports des radiologistes les risques
que des soldats soient pénalisés seller
radiographies sont perdus sont donc
limités selon marc dauphin les forces
armées confirme qu'elle tente de
récupérer les images et disent regretter
tout inconvénient que cette situation
peut causer à ses membres d'un bout à
l'autre du pays
ici alexandre duval radio canada québec